hey youtubers welcome back to my season
for countdown today we're going to talk
about some movies so george RR martin
recently revealed that they are working
on some Game of Thrones movies they're
seriously being considered but not until
the series is done and everyone pretty
much agrees that there's at least seven
or eight seasons of material so we're
talking like 20 19 before we're gonna
see one of these the movies he talked
about mostly had to do with some of the
expanded material you know like Duncan
egg Blackfyre rebellion night King you
get the idea you know all those awesome
stories that you wanted to see but they
just don't have time or money to do
right now hopefully what we'll see is
like a Star Wars situation a better
version of the Big Star Wars Expanded
Universe on screen so what I'm going to
do is my top five stories that I think
would make for the best movies so quick
shut up for my countdown if you're
finding me for the first time I'm just
doing a special video countdown to the
season 4 premiere be sure to subscribe
to get everything and leave me any
suggestions on videos that you want to
see me do my next one is going to be a
Q&A video tomorrow so be sure to leave
me all your questions so here we go
number 5 the hedge knight also known as
Duncan egg dunk is just short for sir
Duncan the tall an egg is the nickname
for the future King Aegon Targaryen the
fifth the series takes place when Aegon
was like brands age right now he was sir
Duncan Squire all the dunk and egg stuff
takes place about 90 years before the
current events in the show Martin has
already written a lot of this novella in
the legends anthology was what kind of
started it off it became the first dunk
and egg story and ended up later getting
turned into a comic book at Marvel so if
you wanted to read a game of thrones
comic book you can actually do that
right now it's an ongoing series there
are also two other novellas called sworn
sword and the mystery night and a fourth
one called the she-wolves of Winterfell
is currently being planned for another
anthology this year so Martin has
already spent a ton of time developing
all these characters so it would make
the most sense for a movie or another
spin-off TV series plus they can just
reuse most of the costumes from the show
just because it happens so close to the
current events the dunk and egg stories
also overlap with the Blackfyre
rebellion the Bloodraven and the war of
the nine penny kings so this material
could just be the backbone for a whole
new series of movies you know not
one and as a side note if you're just
super bummed that wins the winner is
taking so long to get here just read
these dunk and egg stories because they
are awesome number four the Blackfyre
rebellion so King Aegon the fourth you
know unanimously voted worst king in the
history of Westeros legitimizes all of
his bastards warna that makes a claim on
the Iron Throne and it becomes the
second major civil war in the history of
the kingdom the primary characters are
daemon Blackfyre who started the
rebellion the Bloodraven his
half-brother and King Derron the second
interesting sidenote one of the other
black fire bastards escaped at the end
of all this to the east and formed a
gold company one of the most famous
groups of mercenaries there were a bunch
of other bastards involved in that too
the whole thing started because Aegon
the fourth thought his son Darren was
secretly fathered by his brother so he
gave his Valyrian sword called black
fire to his bastard son Damon
legitimizing him people kind of
associated this really famous sword that
had been passed down from Aegon the
first the copper as a visual sign of
succession so whenever you gave the
sword to someone it was like saying you
wanted them to become the next king and
civil war blew up everywhere but
remember there were a ton of huge
characters involved in all these events
number three the Bloodraven also known
as Brynden rivers one of the other
bastards of Aegon the fourth there's so
much story that this character is
involved in the first and second black
fire rebellions he was handed the king
for a long time he was present during
all the dunk and egg stories and he was
a magic-user primarily using glamouring
which is just you know changing your
features like Jack and hogar he also
became the last greenseer in may or may
not be part of season four unconfirmed
of all the characters in the Song of Ice
and Fire he is definitely one of the
most interesting but because his story
kind of spills over into what's
happening now I don't want to include
too many spoilers but feel free to ask
me more questions about him in the
comments below number two the dance of
the Dragons first major Targaryen Civil
War Martin actually just published this
as a novella in the dangerous women
anthology that's the short version
there's actually a complete history that
he's writing for a new book after he's
done with all the regular Song of Ice
and Fire books it's called fire and
blood and it's going to be the complete
history of the Targaryen house for this
movie idea
or two idea I'm mostly focusing on the
dance of the Dragons event but you get
the idea you can do a whole new TV
series told exclusively from the
Targaryen perspective across the entire
history of Westeros it's not that
there's no ideas for other series it's
just that there's way too many good
ideas if you haven't read the short
story the dance is just a civil war that
started right up to the death of the
king and involves his son and his
daughter from another woman and a whole
lot of dragons the real attraction to
this story is that it becomes a war
fought on the backs of dragons mostly
distinguished by their color one of the
big problems of the Targaryen succession
was that they engaged in the kind of
sister wives that Jaime and Cersei had
been doing so whenever they cheated on
each other they did it with other
Targaryen so sometimes what ended up
happening is as you had boil bastards
being born inside the line of succession
just making things super complicated and
my number one pick for a game of thrones
movie filling in the gaps of the current
events on the show even though the show
does an amazing job of telling the book
story it still leaves a lot of stuff out
an extra movie would be an easy way to
just fill in all those gaps like telling
the full story of Jon Snow's mother
Robert's rebellion and other things that
george RR martin hasn't even paid off
yet Martin will sometimes drop minor
plots like the idea of Syrio Forel being
really Jack & Hoag are little things
like that and most of the time on the
show is just dedicated to things
happening in Westeros but you have the
frozen north beyond the wall and stuff
happening in the East there are two more
books coming and Martinez said that we
will get our first look at the distant
north you know called the lands of
always winter guess which book that's
coming in but using a movie right after
the series finishes you know season 8
would be a really easy way to just mop
up any loose plots that they didn't have
time or money to do during the actual
show but now it's your turn though if
they do a game of thrones movie after
the series is over would you like to see
them do something with the current
characters or do you want to see a
prequel story you know like with the
dunk and egg stuff remember posting that
Q&A video tomorrow so leave me all your
questions in the comments below and
click here to get all the other
countdown videos and click here to learn
about the first couple of episodes in
season 4 and a bunch of winds of winter
stuff
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tonight high fives